members of the National Guard are being
deployed across the country to help
States mitigate the other painful
reality from the pandemic hunger lines
are stretching for miles in state after
state as the millions of Americans now
living on the edge are facing
disruptions in the food distribution
chain the challenge is expected to get
worse Mireya Villarreal reports how long
you been here 8:15 like the lines for
free food in New Orleans desperation is
growing by the day
most of these first-time families are
filled with fear and uncertainty what
are you missing at home what's across
the country seams of gratitude for the
most basic needs like at this Food
Kitchen in Washington DC the National
Guard helping with these lines in Boston
stretching several blocks seventeen
million more Americans could now face
hunger because of the corona virus
pandemic back in New Orleans at a small
church pantry we met Troy Rawls and
Carolyn Caston both are newly unemployed
no shops no tourists no income was it
hard to go there was there any sort of
reluctance not whatsoever I mean it's
nothing to be ashamed of everybody
sometimes get down on their luck mashed
potatoes you don't want to eat up
everything now at one time assuming you
don't get something else because you
don't know where next something else I
come from the couple has just enough
money saved to keep up with essential
bills for a few months and they're
starting to ration their food when you
live in you don't have to worry about
surviving because you know you're living
and it's a different right now it's
survival mode the New Orleans Food Bank
helped more than 2,500 families on
Thursday they gave out more than a
hundred and forty three thousand pounds
of food the national organization
feeding America says if they are going
to respond to these needs over the next
six months they're gonna need an
additional 1.4
billion dollars for CBS this morning
Saturday media via al in New Orleans
Louisiana